Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. We're back with your host ex
Amazon ex-boyfriend and experienced
Jordan. Um, okay. Let's go ahead and get
into this video today. Quick
announcement. If you haven't noticed, I
have actually finally got a haircut
after like 4 months and somehow went
from looking Jewish to even more Jewish.
So, all of these things considered,
let's go ahead and get into this new
series. Uh, I promised a bunch of you I
would eventually do some low-level
design on this channel and uh, I'm
extremely hung over today and didn't
really feel like putting too much
thought into this, so I've opted into
going with tic-tac-toe. Uh, we're going
to go ahead and cover the general
premise behind, you know, I guess what
it is that we're looking to do, how we
can efficiently make uh, a decently
thoughtout class, and then most
importantly, make sure that we get the
algorithm correct. So, let's go ahead
and do all those things and jump into
it. All right. So, to do our typical
discussion of the problem before we
really look into any code, uh we're
going to be building tic-tac-toe today.
The one slight change in requirements
that I'm going to make is instead of
necessarily doing uh a 3x3 tic-tac-toe
as is tradition, we're going to extend
this problem to make it such that we're
doing an N byN tic-tac-toe. So, the
typical um solution uh that we you know
like most people would implement when
actually checking for a win in
tic-tac-toe, we're going to have to
optimize that quite a bit in order to go
ahead and make sure that it's going to
run if say we were running on a million
by a million board of tic-tac-toe. So,
just to quickly cover it, what is
tic-tac-toe for those of you who I don't
know why you wouldn't know what it is,
but whatever, we'll quickly cover it.
Uh, tic-tac-toe is traditionally a 3x3
uh, board where you have two players.
One is placing X's, one is placing O's.
And the entire point of the game is that
each player moves uh, you know, in
sequence with one another. So player one
goes, then player two, then player one,
player two. And the entire point of the
game is for you to get uh, three in a
row. So that means you can have
basically three of your X's unencumbered
in a row, three of your X's unencumbered
in a column, and you can also do the two
diagonals of the 3x3 grid. So basically
that's kind of the the layout of this
problem. And now that we have that,
let's start getting into the actual
solution that we want to be building.
All right, so let's go ahead and take a
look at some code. Um, as you can see, I
have our basically driver interface
defined right here. And I've ultimately
elected to define three classes in
total. We've got a player class, a board
class, and a game class. Um, I've
elected to use Python. So, if there's
any Python specific syntax that I've
used in this video, I'll make sure to
actually explain what I went ahead and
did. Um, as you can see, all I'm doing
is declaring a player Jordan, uh, with
the name Big Dick Jordan, who is going
to be the X. We've got Musk, who's going
to be my opponent with the name O. We've
got a board of size 3x3. And then
finally, a game class with a method play
game that we'll be calling uh, which
works. I know this is actually the first
time you guys have ever seen me write
code on this channel. I mean, maybe I
didn't in fact even write it. Maybe I
don't know how to code and maybe I
plagiarized it, but that's for me to
know and you all to find out. So,
anyways, let's go into our player class,
which we're going to go ahead and
reveal. The player class is pretty
simple. All we have is an initializer
method. This is basically the
constructor if you're familiar with
something like Java. And all it's going
to do is take in a name and a marker
where the marker is basically whether
you're going to be X or O. Moving
onwards, let's look into our board
class. This is where the majority of the
logic for our uh you know basically
interview question is going to come into
play. So we're going to spend the most
time talking about this. Okay. So we
have three methods within board and the
first one is going to be our
initializer. Basically all I'm doing is
calling this reset method in the event
that um you know maybe throughout the
game it may make sense to reset the
board after someone wins or loses. So I
figured it was important to have this
method. As you can see, I've commented
that the reset method is going to reset
the board to an initial state, and it's
going to take in a size. So, all that's
really going to do is the following.
It's going to create a 2D array, which
is going to represent our board. And for
any space in our board that's unfilled,
we're just going to use an empty string
to go ahead and represent that.
Additionally, you'll see that I've
declared these four other fields: row
counts, column counts, diagonal counts,
and size. Size is pretty
self-explanatory, but what are row
counts, column counts, and diagonal
counts? Well, in order to understand
these fields, let's actually start by,
you know, thinking about how we should
create our algorithm in order to quickly
determine who's winning. So, as we know
in tic-tac-toe, every single time that a
player moves, we have to check whether
they've won or not, or if the game is
still going, or of course, if there's
going to be a tie when the board is
filled up. So, one of the things that's
kind of important here is that we need
to say to ourselves, okay, uh, we have
basically just placed an X somewhere on
the board. Has our player just won. And
how can you check this? Well, you could
basically loop over the entirety of the
board, check every single row and
column, and see if one of those rows or
columns, or actually the forward and
reverse diagonal, are completely filled
up by X's and O's. However, that's not a
very efficient way. If you think about
the time complexity of that, it's
actually just going to be O of N^ squ,
which is not very good, especially as
our board is going to increase in size
because we mentioned we're not just
playing on a 3x3 board. Hence, we can't
just brute force this where we check
every single row and column. So, what
could we do instead? Well, a slightly
improved solution would be to only go
ahead and check the rows and columns of
every single uh row and column that is
affected by a move, right? So, if I were
to place an X, you know, in the top left
corner of the board, what would happen
is I would only have to check basically
the top row and the leftmost column to
see if that move has basically filled up
that entire row or that entire column
and made the player who is placing the
X's win. However, even there, that's not
necessarily the most efficient thing.
The reason for this being that it's
still linear time complexity. Every
single time that I would make a move, I
would have to loop linearly through that
column and row and possibly even the
diagonals if the move was in a forward
or a reverse diagonal. And I would
linearly loop through those and check to
see if the player has won. And linear
time, while much better than quadratic
time, is still unacceptable for this
problem. Ideally, what we really want is
constant time. And this is actually
something that we can do. So what if
every single time that we placed an X or
an O, we actually kept track for each
row, column, and diagonal, the counts of
X's and O's that are uh basically
included in them. Right? So if I were to
place an X in the top left corner of our
grid, what we would do is the following.
We would say, okay, take the leftmost
column and increment its counter of X's
by one. Take the topmost row and
increment its counter of X's by one. and
also take the forward diagonal and
increment its counter of X's by one. So
now every single time that we go ahead
and place an X or an O, we can actually
increment all of those counters and then
check those relevant rows and columns to
see if the number of X's or O's in that
row is equal to the size of the board.
Right? So if we have a 3x3 board, we
would say, well, are there three X's in
this column? Because if there are, that
means that that player has just won. If
there's not, then the game can keep
going. So that's basically the logic
that we're going to be implementing. And
now I'm going to show you the code for
it. Basically, we're going to place a
marker from a given player at a location
on board. And all this function is going
to do is if the game is now over, we're
going to return true. And if it's not,
we're going to return false. So
basically, I'm just uh you know creating
this variable marker, which is just
going to be the marker from the player
to just shorten our code a little bit.
But the first thing I'm going to
actually do is check if our underlying
2D array has that spot already filled,
meaning there's an X or an O there
already, then we're just going to raise
an error, and we can handle that in our
driver code. Otherwise, we're going to
go ahead and set the location of that
board to the X or O. And furthermore,
we're going to actually take our row
counts, which in Python is a dictionary.
That's a hashmap in Java. But just think
of it as, you know, it's going to say
for a given index of a row, how many X's
it has and how many Y's it has. And so
I'm basically now saying that for the
given row count at a given row, for the
marker X, for example, we're going to
increment that count by one. The same
logic would apply if the marker was an
O. And so now what we're going to
finally do then is check if the count of
X at that row is equal to the size or
basically the length of the board. We're
going to return true. meaning that a
player has just won. We can do this same
exact corresponding logic for the column
counts where we're actually going ahead
and uh basically incrementing the
counter of x's and o's as necessary in
the correct column. And then
additionally, if x is equal to y,
meaning we're we're putting in uh you
know like a marker uh at a coordinate
where x is equal to y in our array, then
we know that we're on the forwards
diagonal. And similarly, if x + y is
equal to the size of the actual array or
rather the length of it uh minus one, we
know that we're on the reverse diagonal.
We're basically doing, you know, some
sort of geometry and creating a line
equation here. And that way we can
increment the corresponding counters of
the backwards diagonal. And again, every
single time that we're actually doing a
marker placing, we're making sure to
check if it's now the case that there
are as many X's or O's in that
corresponding area as the size of the
array. And if there are, we know that a
winner has just been declared. Now, it's
actually occurring to me that I did not
in fact uh write in the tying logic
here. But really all it comes down to is
we could have an additional counter in
board called number of markers placed
which you would increment every single
time there's a successful placement of a
marker. And if the number of markers
placed is equal to the size squared we
know that the game can no longer
continue and there must have been a tie.
Uh the game class is not really
necessary. I think you could probably
mostly do driver code, but I did do it
just to clean things up a little bit
where basically the game class takes in
a board, a player one, and a player two,
and increments a current turn, which is
done to make sure that we know the
current player is actually going to be
the right one. Right? We want their
turns to be uh switching back and forth
between X and O as opposing to let the
player who has X go multiple times in a
row. So, all I'm really doing here, this
code isn't too important, is getting the
input uh for, you know, basically where
you want to place your X or O, going
ahead and doing that, and if the game is
finished, you print that that person
wins. And then finally, we have our
driver code.
All right, so pretty simple stuff for
the most part. Uh, another reason that I
wanted to do a more simple problem for
kind of the first episode of this series
is to get some more feedback from you
guys, um, in terms of what worked about
the way I presented this problem and
what didn't. Uh, obviously, whenever I'm
going to make a new type of video, I
want to be sure that I'm presenting
solutions in a way that's effective to
convey, you know, what it is that I'm
trying to get across. And so yeah, I'd
really appreciate it if you guys took a
look at this in the comments section and
tried to give me some input on how I
could kind of better present the actual
solution to the problem. Uh again, this
one is mostly just about that algorithm
and getting the winchecking from O of
N^2 to O of 1. And if you got that part
down, then you're pretty much good to
go. It's not too important how you
organize your code in these problems,
especially when there's like a trick
about time complexity. And often times
in these low-level design problems,
there's going to be one element of it
that the interviewer really wants to
hone down on to make sure that you can
kind of see where the algorithmic nature
of the problem is. And in this case,
it's the windchecking part. So again
guys, I hope this video helped. Um, and
yeah, I'm looking forward to hearing